hi Matt here before we get started I've
invited our amazing executive producer
Jenny Luna to share some exciting news
thanks Matt think fast talk smart the
podcast was recognized at the recent
Webby Awards we were an honoree for
interview talk show and we received best
overall business podcast episode
we are humbled and grateful for this
recognition we want to thank the entire
team that works tirelessly behind the
scenes to bring this show to you and
most importantly we want to thank all of
you for your support now let's listen in
to the award-winning episode when Matt
talked with GSB Professor Jonathan lavav
[Music]
as a kid I love telling knock-knock
jokes my friends and family will tell
you my jokes were really not funny
however I persisted I distinctly
remember being so excited every time my
humor victims would respond to my knock
knock with a who's there this decision
of an audience to engage with a speaker
is critical for communication success
today we'll explore our audience's
decision making and communication I'm
Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
I am really excited to speak with
Jonathan lavav Jonathan is the king
philanthropies professor of marketing at
the GSB he also directs the gsb's
behavioral lab
Jonathan's research is aimed at
understanding consumers judgments and
choices by using tools from experimental
psychology and behavioral economics in
particular he studies the contextual
factors that influence people's choices
and judgments thanks for being here
Jonathan thanks for having me Matt I
want to start by talking about the
impact of context on our decisions
action in communication a while back you
conducted research involving judges in
their sentencing can you share what you
found and what your results might mean
for how people make decisions when
prisoners have completed two-thirds of
their sentence they're automatically
eligible for parole it doesn't mean
they're automatically automatically
paroled it means they're eligible for
parole and basically the way the setup
was is the prisoners come in and they're
dressed in this orange get up just like
you see in the movies and they present
in front of the judge sometimes they
have a lawyer sometimes they don't and
the judge makes the decision whether or
not to release them on parole and what
we did is we took a look to see which
prisoners were released
and what we found was that if you
plotted imagine you have an X Y plane
right imagine a graph so on the x-axis
you have ordinal position what does it
mean ordinal position are you first are
you the second prison right third fourth
fifth and so on and so forth so we had
that on one axis and on the other axis
what we had is the uh your probability
of being released okay so for example if
you were uh first in the sequence your
chances of being released were sixty
percent and so when we plotted that we
observed a really interesting sort of
EKG looking pattern where initially you
were reasonably likely to be released
around sixty percent and that kind of
decreased you know as soon as it went up
since it went down a little bit but
overall the pattern was a decrease and
then we observed a jump and then we
observed the same pattern then we
observed another jump and so we have an
interpretation that we didn't test the
interpretation but it's consistent with
it and the idea is that as people make
lots of decisions the previous decisions
have an effect on the subsequent
decisions and specifically as you and
we've all experienced this and we make a
lot of decisions I can meeting you have
a lot of decisions your sort of energy
that you have for the first one is very
different than the energy that you have
for the third one or the fifth one or
the tenth one right and so as you as you
become
depleted let's say the way you solve
that problem is you simplify the
decision for yourself and so what's the
simplest decision so Matt you you came
up you're like sixth or seventh on my
list I've seen five or six or seven
other bad guys before you
you know what easiest thing to do is
just to leave you in prison and so
that's that's what we observed and then
when people took a break there's some
kind of mental replenishment that looks
like it's happening I'm curious to get
your thoughts on what you think this
might mean for people as they think
about when they interact with others it
sounds to me like they have to think
about the amount of decisions that
they're asking people to make or that
people might have made prior to the
decisions we're asking people to make
what what are your thoughts on that how
do we take this research and maybe apply
it to make our communication more likely
to succeed I think the first step is the
realization and the realization is as
follows decisions and information is
cumulative and so that accumulation can
change how we approach the information
and so as a result that accumulation
needs to be managed right suppose I'm
communicating in a classroom and I'm
seeing a lot of stuff and it's a lot a
lot of a lot of information if I Really
Want to Be an Effective Teacher I have
moments during the course where I change
Pace I have people doing exercise I
basically give them the opportunities
for those kind of mental rest bites so
that they can then kind of go back to
then hearing me lecture and they're not
basically fried as they're hearing me do
it and similarly with decisions when
you're in a situation when you're
planning multiple decisions it's
actually a process that you have to plan
out right the problem is is that yes
things will change but we don't always
know in what way but what I can say with
confidence is that is that something
changes and we also have some other
research that shows that giving people a
chance for a mental reset makes your
message and makes their sort of ability
to approach information it replenishes
it and you'll be much more effective so
there's so many things to take away from
what you just said we've talked often
here about knowing your audience and
really trying to understand what they
need to hear from you but you also have
to think about just the psychological
burden that is on your audience and
address that yeah it's not just what
they need to hear from you it's how they
need to hear it right and how they need
to hear it is not a straight line it's a
dynamic process and they need to hear it
one way for a while and then they need
to hear a different way and that
different way needs to reinforce that
one way and then they have to go back to
some other way otherwise you're not
accounting for your audience you're not
actually knowing your audience right and
addressing to their needs in the moment
that's fascinating that's fascinating
I'm going to apply that not only in my
teaching but in my other communication
especially with my kids I definitely
have to say things in a different way in
different timings for sure especially if
they're teenagers they are they are
believe me as someone who studies
marketing and decision making what
suggestions do you have for those of us
who want our ideas to get noticed I'll
share with you two basic principles in
decision making the first one is that
assessments of value are comparative
when I ask you how much is your iPhone
worth to you you don't kind of go to the
back of your mind and do like a
calculation you know and you come out
with a number it's worth right Seventeen
hundred dollars and 25 cents no you say
oh well compared to what
okay so really everything is compared if
I ask you Matt how happy are you with
your net worth
you're gonna answer the question it
depends on who you think about if you
think about you know maybe you grew up
poor maybe and now you're wealthier and
so maybe you'll feel great about it but
maybe you had an ambition for yourself
that you would be a kind of trillionaire
now and you're not there so you feel
poor so the first thing is is to realize
that when people make a decision when
they evaluate you that evaluation is
inherently comparative and your homework
is
to figure out what are people comparing
you to they're going to make that
comparison whether you like it or not
whether you try to control it or not
right so first of all let's figure out
what they're trying to compare us to and
the second thing is let's try to induce
a comparison
that favors us we do that in marketing
all the time with positioning right we
position a product in a way that it's
differentiated relative to the
competition so the advantage becomes
apparent so that's one thing that's one
basic principle the other basic
principle is simplicity
our minds are extremely capable but also
extremely cheap by cheap I mean we want
to make a decision or a judgment
investing the least amount of mental
capacity possible and as a result when
we look at a situation the first thing
we look for are what I call better than
cues in other words I want to be able to
see that an option is better than on
some Dimension than another option and
so in your Communication in your
offering of a product a service I don't
know a menu of whatever it is you want
to highlight those better than cues
because that's what that's that's what
we go to First and the reason we go
there first is because that makes it
easy hey this is better than that done
I'm going home
wow I like both of those I just had a an
assignment in a class where people do a
panel presentation so there are four
people presenting next to each other and
we talked about how that comparison you
have on a panel is very different than
other types of communication because you
literally see the person right next to
you and your audience makes those
comparisons so how do you want to come
off relative to the person sitting to
your left or to your right on a panel
like that unless you're clearly Superior
than everybody else along the along some
Dimension the best thing to do is to
come off as as different as possible so
you're not easy to compare oh
interesting because because otherwise
you're sort of vulnerable to downward
comparisons but if you're in the
incomparable Matt Abrahams uh-huh I
can't compare you okay so he is a
different Beast I'll judge you along
different dimensions I I have been
accused of being very different in many
ways I'm not sure it's always been
positive but but this notion of uh
better than I like a lot as we
differentiate our ideas our messages our
products and services we can really
position it as better than so so it
makes it easier for the audience to make
that decision just one thing careful and
being overly overt it's like when you go
to a restaurant in the oscillator what's
the best wine and they say uh this one
and it's the most expensive wine on the
list and you're like oh okay they're
just trying to stop me the most
expensive wine right but people have
what's called persuasion knowledge right
so yeah you want to have those better
than cues but you don't want to have
those better than cues in such a way
that will raise suspicion that you're
trying to convince people right yes we
talked about that a bit when Zach
tourmala was here about about persuasion
and how how you want to be persuasive
but if it looks like you're being
persuasive it works against you
you ran an online course here at
Stanford for the School of Engineering
entitled leading from home I'd like to
have you share some of the things you
teach in two topic areas first can you
tell us how do you lead when your office
is just a 13-inch screen it's a great
question and to be honest with you it's
something that we're in the process of
figuring out right yes working from home
was growing it was up to about five
percent of the workforce yeah in 2018
but now I think it's you know it's going
to end up being 25 30 or 40 percent
right and we're trying to figure that
out what we teach in that course is we
say let's think about basic elements of
the psychology of the workplace how they
play out face to face and how they might
be different when when your world is
basically reduced to to a 13 inch screen
I'll give an example like Norms when I
go to the office in a face-to-face
office there's all kinds of implicit and
explicit Norms right so you have the
explicit Norms are communicated when you
have employee onboarding or when your
boss talks to you when your colleagues
talk to you that's where you learn what
you're supposed to do and how to do it
exactly right but then there's implicit
Norms like what time do people get in
here in the morning or like what's okay
to wear or what kind of language is it
okay to use like can you curse you know
it's like you know you know throw an f
word from time to time does that make
you seem cooler or does that make you
seem more like like a not a cooler I was
wondering what you're gonna say I have
to be careful I don't I don't know that
this is here this is a G-rated podcast I
don't that's right I don't know the
Norms here so I stopped myself the
hardest thing is to figure out now when
everybody's remote and or distributed
teams and everything is through a
13-inch office what are the norms and so
one of the things that we teach is the
first thing you have to do is you have
to catalog what are the Norms that you
have in the face-to-face world and
what's the purpose of those Norms right
so let's say we have a norm that we
shake hands okay so that Norm what's the
purpose of it is to be able to say I
have a connection I'm here and there's
nothing that says connected more than
physical contact
okay so now let's think about the 13
inch office what are ways in this
environment in which I can create
connectedness so maybe you know I'll
give you a very simple example maybe I
used a handshake Emoji which is I know
it's kind of a lame example but but it's
fulfilling the same obligation exactly
right it's the same obligation so it's
like oh or or maybe it's not a handshake
Emoji maybe it's a different kind of
emoji that like right suggests contact
like a hand up is it right that's like a
certain kind of wave or something like
that and so what we do is we catalog
those types of things so for instance so
Norms is one of them things like
nonverbal cues yeah when you and I are
sitting together in a room there's a
bunch of not like you just nodded I did
okay so you nodded so that suggests to
me hey I hear you when we're doing
things through a screen or we're doing
things imagine for example just with
voice right I don't see the nods I don't
have that non-verbal cue which means
that I as a communicator as a leader
have to find other ways to show that I'm
engaged so I'll say uh-huh right right
maybe I don't naturally say uh-huh but
now I've indicated to you through this
other modality that the equivalent of a
nod right so we go through a catalog of
that stuff and encourage people to join
I think it's one of the most interesting
problems and it speaks to the future of
work absolutely another topic from your
course that piqued my curiosity was how
do you maintain a company culture when
some or all of the employees are remote
short answer it's tough It's not just
maintain a company culture you have to
establish a company right right yeah
first you have to ask yourself wait a
second What's the culture we have What's
the culture we want to have right okay
and then with a bunch of trial and error
actually say okay if I wanted to fulfill
suppose I want to have a culture that's
Innovative okay I want to have an
Innovative culture now I'm far away how
do I create environments for people to
have those serendipitous conversations
where they come up with new ideas so
maybe you have you know some people do
things like before a meeting the first
five minutes are meant for just silly
serendipitous conversation right another
thing you say okay there's research that
suggests that when people go out and
take a walk they're more creative so
maybe you actually encourage employees
to do voice conversations while walking
right right because when you're moving
around you may be physically inspired by
things around you but it's it's a
deliberate process yeah when you do
those walking talks it's hard because
sometimes people are really panting and
sweating as they go but it presumes
being in shape that's right that's right
um this notion of norms symbols and
rituals uh cataloging them and then
thinking very deliberately about what
you want I think is so important I know
you recently delivered a lecture on the
top 12 lessons you've learned about
communication from your many years in
the classroom I would love to have you
share two or three of those lessons with
us here here's the ones that I tend to
repeat a lot uh you have to earn the
right to I said it was a
G-rated all right we'll believe that all
right yeah what that means is that first
a story has to have a core and then it
has to have the refinements and that's
true in any kind of presentation or even
any kind writing a lot of times you see
people they try to use this fancy
language but they use fancy language on
vapid ideas first let's get the
sentences clearly put together right and
then let's add the flare right too many
people think that we start with flair
and if you have flare it's more
attractive it's not right it's style
over substance versus substance over
style exactly right so you have to first
thing you have to earn the right to Bull
poop
and that's that's one thing that that I
quote a lot the other thing that I quote
a lot is actually something that was
taught to me when I first became an
academic I was the Columbia business
school in our our dean of the MBA
program said talking about teaching he
said remember they're hearing it for the
first time which I think is an
absolutely brilliant nugget and it's
true
in any kind of communication whether
it's we're talking whether it's we're in
a room talking to lots of people whether
you have a product the product
essentially is a form of communication
between you and your potential customer
oh yeah yeah and you have to take the
perspective this is a person who's
hearing it for the first time and it's
very hard to do because there's such an
asymmetry between what we know I know
everything and you know nothing right
and I have to feel like someone who
doesn't know anything and that's so so
profoundly difficult that was the the
second thing let me add a third thing
that sure relates to the current
zeitgeist
you can't satisfy everybody but you have
to be mindful of everybody you're not
gonna especially if you have a style
you're not gonna hit the mark with
everybody but that doesn't mean that you
shouldn't be mindful of their needs and
you know needs nowadays are broadly
defined around not just kind of
knowledge but also identity and stuff
like that and and sure you don't have to
be perfect for them but you have to be
mindful of them and that's critical I
think to be able to generate created the
environment in which communication is
effective it reminds me the last point
you brought up reminds me of a lesson
I've shared with many people I've
mentored when I was in the in the
Working World and I was running
organizations you're still in the
Working World at Stanford Matt if that's
true okay when I was in the corporate
world one of the biggest lessons that
was hard for me to learn that I've tried
to pass on to others is there's a
difference between being liked and being
respected yeah and a lot of people want
to be liked and and they'll do things
that that try to accommodate everybody
when in fact that ends up working
against you and it gets to that very
same point you just made before we end
I'd like to ask you the same three
questions I ask everyone who joins me up
for that go for it all right question
number one if you were to capture the
best communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would that
title be I shared it with you already
remember they're hearing it for the
first time so so important I first came
across that when I was an undergrad I
was studying Zen Buddhism and this
notion of beginner's mind and you really
have to just put yourself in that
perspective not just for yourself to
learn and appreciate but to really help
others so it's about empathy and about
really seeing it for the first time
let me ask question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why
I've been around a lot of great
communicators but I think the best one I
ever saw is a guy who's a colleague of
mine of Colombia who's now at HBS whose
name is Sunil Gupta Sunil Gupta was
all content Clarity Crystal Clear slick
without looking slick it was mesmerizing
and he could explain things in such a
clear way he didn't make a show he
didn't pace around he didn't do all that
he didn't need it and so in that sense
he was just absolutely brilliant the guy
would just stand in place and and
communicate let me ask our final
question what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe so the first one is
Clarity and it has to be not it has to
be Clarity to the speaker before its
Clarity to The Listener oh I like that
clarification and so yeah exactly and so
you have to be able to stay in the
middle of night
when you've woken up Suddenly when
someone like throws a glass of water on
you does that happen to you a lot no of
course all the time
um but I have teenagers but right right
but uh if you're not there your listener
will never get there
so I think I think that's the first tip
second tip that I think is critical is
the best communicators are the best at
transitioning from concept to concept oh
that is so cool that is so important
it's just and so underserved people
don't think about it they don't think
about it they think in this world of
slides and so they complete the slide
and they go to the next line they say so
yes and so we're next exactly next so
that's the second part is moving from
idea to idea
I think that the third one is Rapport
that connection
yeah
it's happening with my son once when we
were in the airport and I went to an
agent and first thing I always do when
when I'm in the grocery public place
where you have people serving you is I
look at their name tag and I said like
you know you know Matt Matt what time is
this flight leaving and I could have
just said what time is this flight
leaving but the service I got when I
said Matt what time is the flight
leaving was different because because
Matt was addressed by name and actually
in that specific situation we ended up
getting an upgrade from New York to San
Francisco and I remember my son we like
we walk away and we're walking onto the
plane and he says do you know that
person and I said no I don't I don't
know that person but they have a name
and name and communication is like sugar
you get more with sugar you get more
understanding yeah you get more
connection so so you taught a lesson a
very important lesson to your son about
individuating people and respecting
people and you got the reward for it
yeah and I see it well thank you and
thank you for all that you shared um my
pleasure as we close I have a joke for
you Jonathan I hope you decide to go
along so so here we go knock knock uh
who's there tank tank who no thank you
Matt I told you my jokes were bad but
you weren't kidding in all seriousness
Jonathan thank you so much Not only was
it super fun to talk to you uh it's been
very insightful your suggestions in
teaching about what makes for a
effective decision making and
communication is really helpful and I
wish you well and and I hope everybody
takes an opportunity to learn more about
you and the stuff you do thank you so
much thanks very much Matt appreciate it
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by Stanford University's
Graduate School of Business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stamford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
stanford.gsb